Speaker 1: For some time, we've been worried,
wondering whether it would be August,
when there's another attempt at a sort of Trump
riot, coup insurrection thing in Washington, D.C.,
and thankfully it did not happen in August.
There were questions about the first half
of August and then maybe the second half
of August, and it didn't happen there. Now
actually seems to be a sort of more date
certain. And that date is September 18th,
on which it is increasingly looking as though
there is going to be an attempt to do another
January 6th. On September 18th. The Associated
Press is reporting that per their sources,
intelligence shows extremists plan to attend a
rally at the Capitol on September 18, writing
far right extremist groups like the Proud Boys
and Oath Keepers are planning to attend a rally
later this month at the U.S. Capitol designed
to demand, quote, demand, quote, justice for
the hundreds of people charged in connection
with January's insurrection. Now understand that
they are wanting to protest. What happened
on January 6th in the sense that the alleged
terrorists are being treated too harshly, that's
what the September 18th group has a problem with,
very dangerous. Already the officials have been
discussing security plans that involve I'm sorry,
hold on. As a result, U.S. Capitol Police have
been discussing in the recent weeks whether the
large perimeter fence that was erected after the
January riot needs to go back up. The officials
have been discussing security plans that involve
reconstructing the fence, as well as another
plan that does not involve a fence. They were not
authorized to speak publicly and spoke to the AP
on the condition of anonymity. The planned
September 18 rally at the Capitol comes as a
jittery Washington has seen a series of troubling
one off incidents, including, most recently,
a man who parked a pickup near the Library of
Congress said he had a bomb and a detonator,
which I was on break when that happened. Among
the most concerning events, a series of unexploded
pipe bombs placed around the Capitol ahead of
the January 6th insurrection remain unexplained,
and no suspect has been charged. That story has
almost been forgotten completely. Pipe bombs
around D.C., we don't know who put them there.
Nobody charged on Capitol Hill. The politics
around fencing in the iconic building and its
grounds were extremely difficult for lawmakers.
Many said they disliked closing off access, but
acknowledged the security it provided. Yeah,
and unfortunately and we're going to talk
about what might happen on the 18th from
a law enforcement standpoint, anything you do to
try to mitigate risk for the 18th will be called
authoritarian by the right. If you put the fence
back up because of the threats from these people,
these very people will say this is part of the
authoritarian left locking down Washington, D.C.,
you really can't win. And so you have to do simply
what is what is indicated by the intelligence you
have from the standpoint of safety. The deadly
riot overwhelm the police force. The planned
presence of extremist groups is concerning because
while members and associates of the Oath Keepers
and proud boys make up just a fraction of the
nearly six hundred people charged in the riot,
they are facing, some of the most serious
charges brought so far include allegations
that they conspired to block the certification
of Joe Biden's victory. Several Oath Keepers
have pleaded guilty to conspiracy charges and are
cooperating in cases against fellow extremists
as officials prepare for this month's rally.
Yogananda Pitmen, the Capitol Police official
who led intel operations for the agency
when rioters descended on the building
has been put back in charge of intelligence.
Capitol Police Chief Tom Manger said the
department is closely monitoring September 18.
So it looks like there is a really good shot
that something is going to go down on the
18th. Are the police going to be fully prepared
in advance this time? Let's hope so. Is the
National Guard going to be there or standing by in
a reasonable way where it doesn't take hours for
them to get there this time? Let's hope so. Now,
just for a moment, consider if this were rather
than sort of a white militia types, if these were
Muslim groups, for example, or black groups,
for example, would this be handled the same way?
I think the answer is obviously not. Now, those on
the right will say it wouldn't be handled the same
way because these people aren't really a risk. But
if it were Muslims or black people, they would be
a risk. That's what the right would say. We would
say that the perception is very, very different
from law enforcement. And we know that it is from
the data that we've looked at for many years in
that we've even done very long form videos on
in detail. We know that the perception of threat
is very different. That's weird. Hair just got
caught in my shirt there. The perception of threat
is very different from law enforcement, in part
depending on the identity of the individuals
involved. Whether you look at it as fortunate or
unfortunate, I think it is far more likely police
will be better prepared this time. And that is
going to be part of the persecution complex,
the victimhood complex that whoever is going to
show up on September 18th ultimately will use.
They'll say, look at what they did. They sent in
the big guns they sent in the cavalry because they
are targeting us that this is what the ralliers,
writers, if they become that will say. So it's
sort of a lose lose. But if it's lose lose in the
PR sense either way, then you've got to do what is
going to keep Washington, D.C. and people safe.
And let's hope that this time they are prepared.